[Music]
hi I'm Jessica Osorio I'm a journalist
and a communication specialist from
Guatemala I have visited the course with
more important revolutions for everyone
because made a very interesting
professional term for me and my
professional team I have been working a
remote for the last six years for the
knowledge that I got through this
Harvard online course and only to
organize my time based on my well-being
tour reviews the possibility and making
mistakes the reason why I try to
complete and certificate and finally be
part of the caribacterial community of
learners
rather I kneel to improve my skills and
because of the pride of having support
for one of the best universities in the
world thank you Hallmark online
[Music]